how do everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay
um someone just sent me a text they're
trapped in the apartments or something I
don't know what apartments but I guess
these lead to them ah oh darn it ah come
here darn bad at the jumping ah ma'am
oh I can double tap Drake ah yeah crouch
jump like a mouse yeah come on get some
ladder ladder coming so they are the top
that's right you knew what was good for
you
monsters ah let's just leaves the
apartments those apartments look dark
dot dot dot oh boy oh boy
no it does not feel right bro dude man
dawg
fourth-floor whoo howdy am i normal my
number 3 little
kiddies playing in the park said the
first Kitty let's go home before it gets
dark the first two went on their merry
way home the third stay playing all done
come here child come to me the something
whispered sadly they say curiosity
killed the cat oh I see okay let's go
home
the bushes whispered something okay
okay I had that I almost had them right
that was a terrible head run
okay the fourth floor
I know I said I was gonna remember how
to figure out how to do a wheel but I
didn't actually take a break in between
so say be save I guess I'll just make do
Atari yeah haha oh you were the one with
you ah get out of here huh
right with you Oh Oh like a little kid
oh what's wrong with your face Oh
oh man oh man
budge okay Oh what are these things why
is this happening okay can't go down oh
I can't go down okay maybe there's a
secret or something maybe it's a
horrible death awaiting me
ah back off oh you was Lum little kid
huh oh what oh what that dodge hahah so
pro Oh sad in the face Oh got you I'm so
pro at this game it's not even funny
oh yeah block from the other side I
don't even know where the heck I'm going
ah probably not going the right way
okay I'm going in random roads I don't
know why oh come on budge ah look at
that
ho ho ho is this those little kitties
are so cute they look so lovely I just
want to touch them but then those
parents comes that's why I have to kill
them okay this is some sort of pedophile
murderer sorry I keep pressing the
escape button okay I'm going in another
one Oh
okay this is the horrible murders place
okay spring I shouldn't just pick up
random syringes Oh Louis death yet oh oh
ha no no no ha give me out let me out
let me out was that Oh using it in it ah
come on come on it ah I got it I got it
how do I use it
ha ha ha you're real yeah what are you
the wife huh uh-oh what happened here
you got like a spike coming out of your
neck Oh
Oh Oh let me out let me out let me out
all the doors locked
something's crying I don't care you're
on your own buddy just going to save the
person on the 4th floor who's probably
not even a person probably a monster
okay good I don't want to go in the
third floor I don't want to go on any
other floor besides my objective all
right maybe I'll check up here and I'm
syringe probably has AIDS oh come on I
have a neighbor across oh I should have
read that a while ago okay so I gotta go
back in the second floor yep yep yep
book oh no that's right back off okay
haver across I'm sure it's gonna be
perfectly normal
oh wait this is I'm stupid I went right
back in the same one I'm an idiot
all right let's locked ok i got a key
use okay there okay is there huh huh huh
get get some castle good no quick for
you Oh got you ha ha the guy I don't
have any room oh but I dodge right
through the wall
come on Oh can't get through the wall ah
bring the fight to you uh-huh
no I can't yeah there we go
hello kill them hit him at least
Jebus okay ah come on what the heck all
right there we go finally die jeez I
need to I need a syringe or something
maybe strong stuff so I better be
careful with okay right into arm yeah oh
good stuff
oh that's the stuff okay whoa I did it
oh I don't know how but I did okay good
enough finally I took way longer than it
should've okay so alright ah you oh I
got my flashlight on you you're not so
scary
alright you're pretty terrifying but
whatever that's right I got you
loser loser loser there's something in
the ceiling Oh a gun gimme gimme gimme
I don't care if it's about a it's a gun
yeah better take it with me he in the
gun that makes sense
hulky oh thank is a gun magazine
oh let's stick with the knife for now I
just got a press both of the keys once
get it to work
unlock the lock okay oh where am i where
am I
okay go back to the fourth floor now I
got the hall key I could probably get in
this game is tense
all right how do i how did I do that
again oh man I don't know what the hell
huh
but was the other door not budge or was
it locked in a normal bus so it's not
going to open so let's just open
something on the second floor sorry I'm
going to get circles guys I'll figure
this out uh vegetable I do have a brain
of some sort but that's gonna have to
wait till the next part so thank you
guys so much for watching hope you're
enjoying it so far and I will see you in
the next part
bye-bye